اذا ما تاهلنا ما راح تتاهلوا هذه كانت
كلمات امارتي مدافعه غانا بعد مباراه
الاوروغواي امبارح باختصار هاي الجمله
بتعبر عن وجهه نظر الجمهور الغاني وجهه
نظر لاعبي غانا اتجاه لويس سواريز على وجه
التحديد ما عندهم مشكله مع الاوروجواي
عندهم مشكله
امبارح اترسخت او تاكدت بمباراه المنتخب
كاس العالم 2022 الي صار امبارح انه من
بدايه المباراه والجمهور الغاني كلمه
يستلم الكره لويس سواريز كان في اصوات
صافرات استهجان مع كل لمسه لسواريز على
الكره وتحصل منتخب غانا على ركله جزاء
بالبدايه ضيعها طبعا اندرياس وبعد ذلك
نجحت الاوروجواي بتسجيل هدف وهدفين
وبالتالي الجمهور الغني وهم بلاش يحس انه
راحت فرصه تاهل من يده ولكن الاهم الا
تتاهل الاوروغواي الاهم انه ما ينبسط لويس
بعد هذه المباراه والسبب هو اللي بيرجع او
بياخذنا لعام 2010 بعام 2010 التقط ارجوي
وغانا في ربع نهائي كاس عالم اللي كان
مقام في جنوب افريقيا وفي تلك المباراه
ضرب احد لاعبي غانا الكره براسه بالاشواط
اضافيه والويس سواريز تصدر لتلك الكره على
خط المرمى بيده بشكل طبعا غير شرعي واخذ
بطاقه حمراء واتحصلت غانا على ركله جزاء
اهدرها اسموا اجيان في تلك اللحظه وتحول
الدموع سواريز وقلقوا لما كان مغادر ارضيه
الملعب الى فرحه عالميه اسطوريه بلقطه
تاريخيه ما حدا بينساها
من ذلك اليوم لعام 2022 الجمهور الغانم ما
نسي الجمهور الغانم بحمل لويس سواريز سبب
عدم تاهل غاناك اول فريق افريقي لنصف
نهائي كاس العالم في تلك النسخه وبالتالي
عنوانه الصحف الغنيه وكان حديث الجماهير
الغنيه معظمها قبل مباراه امبارح عن
الانتقام من لويس سواريز عن التاهل على
حساب الاورغواي واذا لم نتاهل فلن تاهل
الاوروجواي طبعا اللي صار انه كوريا
الجنوبيه سجلت هدف على البرتغال وفازت
بهدفين مقابل هدفيد وبالتالي صارت هي
المتاهله بفارق الاهداف لدور الثاني
والارغواي غادرت لتتحول احزان غانا وغضبها
الشديد من الويس سواريز اللي اصبح الشيطان
كما يسمونه في غانا الى افراح
وتحولت افراح الويس سواريز الى احزان في
لقطه على التاريخ يعتقد ان غانا انتقمت
فيها من حادثه 2010 بعد انتهاء دوري
المجموعات من كاس العالم 2022 هذه توقعات
لدور 16 من هذه البطوله هولندا امريكا
هولندا سوف تاهل الى الدور ربع النهائي
الارجنتين واستراليا الارجنتين الاقرب
للتاهل الى ربع النهائي فرنسا بولندا
فرنسا الاقرب للوصول الى الدوري المقبل
انجلترا السنغال السنغال قد تقوم بمفاجاه
على انجلترا واعتقد انه السنغال اقتصاد
ربع النهائي اليابان كرواتيا اليابان اقرب
للوصول الى ربع النهائي
البرازيل كوريا الجنوبيه البرازيل في
الدوري القادم
اسبانيا المغرب اسبانيا
في الدوري القادم